what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in and
also guys we are doing meetups in the US
and the UK so if you want to be a part
of those make sure you sign up to our
Google form that is in the description
below
um okay guys so today I'm reacting to a
content creator that he's actually
really good at explaining
um the mgtow point of view so for those
of you that don't know mgtow's men going
their own way basically this is a sector
of YouTube that men that don't really
want to have relationships with women
um there's different and he explained
this in one so I'm sorry if I'm
butchering this but he basically said
there's a couple different points of
mgtow some guys will date girls casually
but outside of that they won't really
deal with women some guys avoid women
altogether even just like normal
interactions with women and some are
just walk walking away from marriage so
there is a little bit of discrepancies I
think correct me if I'm wrong but um I
just thought that he was a really good
content creator so um let's roll the
footage let's play the play the clip all
right 99 of women are unattractive wow
hi everyone Sandman here this video is
brought to you by a donation from a
feline that's more hated than Mr
Bigglesworth and that would be fat cat
here's what she briefly has to say hey
say man this is a bonus donation if you
want to talk about something else then
the me three email that I sent you it's
perfectly I liked your Chapel in the
Hills video it's too bad I can't
actually do donations for the cool
buildings Channel I guess this will have
to do for your information a cousin of
mine decided my place would be great for
a small Christmas party I'm hosting
decorating and in charge of shopping and
food it's a welcome distraction and
scary how on point the video is turning
out to be well Miss Fat Cat thanks for
the kitty litter update and since he
didn't give me a specific topic I'll be
covering something that I noticed in the
last year or two after going through the
second red pill rage stage phase 2.0
after I started dating I haven't dated
anyone for almost two years now because
I almost immediately find faults with
women because I know what red flags to
look for automatically and my big head
now overrides my little one apparently
I'm not the only one that feels this way
I found a mgtail Reddit post and I'm
putting in the description it takes us
to a page where there are tons of other
guys that feel the exact same way okay
now this one thing
although they're just constantly we're
just constantly pointing out the flaws
in women I've been accused of a grift
you know blah blah blah anyways but let
me let me explain it to you so when you
think about the
women in history have been valued for
right it's Purity youth fertility
um being you know attractiveness and
nowadays it's like do women really have
what we historically have been valued
for I mean think think about it like
what percent of women getting married
are virgins today when I looked it up a
hundred years ago only I think it was 15
or 20 percent of women had um admitted
to having pre-marital sex right and it's
like even if okay let's say we double
that let's say they're lying
um and you know it's actually 40 that
that still means half of women getting
married we're virgins now as women we're
not that anymore what percent of us are
overweight it's like 70 to 80 percent uh
what percent of us only have kids in
wedlock I don't know but it's it's a lot
higher than it used to be and what
percent of women actually submit and
really have been taught to be a wife and
really have been taught to LIT to be in
a to additional relationship and how and
to respect men and when you start
narrowing it down we could because this
is the conservatives will come by and
say well not all women are like that
well you know to a lot of guys most
women are like that and there are
exceptions but we'll even see prominent
conservatives you know getting divorced
where it's like those are the guys that
are supposed to pick like the more
traditional women and even the
traditional women they pick divorce them
so the men are just getting really
frustrated and I I see where they're
coming from if I'm being honest it's
just one of the people posting a comment
there says that the enchantment is gone
another guy says that women are as
useful to mgtow as scuba gear is to a
camel yet another guy had this to say
and I quote you wanted a life partner
not an object and do you find objects
like your television microwave and car
all that special when sex is restricted
to marriage between two people it felt
special and people had to attract people
with traits that were not sexual unquote
and yet another guy thinks it's the Mind
creating a self-defense mechanism to
protect you from falling in love I guess
I agree with all those points I guess
it's a bit from all of them but I would
go even further it's like there's a part
of me that just became entirely
apathetic and stopped caring completely
about the opposite sex I saw a woman
fall down flat on her derriere and I
didn't care in fact I actually wanted to
wave my arms in the air like I just
didn't care as well God damn
I don't want to see anyone fall you know
okay I am I am an exception to this rule
all right because when I see someone
fall in general I never laugh I have
never been one to laugh I've always been
one and I would always piss me off
because I fall a lot when people would
laugh at me when I fell and when other
people fall I just want to help them up
or say are you okay you know sorry I
just I need to that triggered me created
by treating men poorly and when men
realize what female nature is all about
after taking the red pill we simply stop
giving women attention validation
resources and any of the other things
that they want they all think that we're
always going to seek them out because we
just can't help ourselves but it's
simply not true the more men learn about
female nature and safe in Anonymous ways
on the internet the more women will
suffer as a result the way that women
seem to actually been dealing with men's
apathy is to wear more makeup put more
effort into their appearance and do more
to get a man's interest and commitment
everything from putting out on the first
date to playing the female chameleon and
pretending to like all the same things
that he does even for many years if the
guy is a good catch and they know it
they'll do whatever it takes to keep his
attention they have to because don't you
know where have all the good men gone
but for men going Our Own Way once you
realize that women don't return our love
in the same way that we love them and
once we realize that we don't want them
because they become increasingly
unattractive no man that fully
comprehends that to most women he's uh
human doing instead of a human being
will find most women attractive unless
they have something special about them
my pseudos yeah and I think that's like
and people get so mad about this where
it's like women don't love you for who
you are and at first when I heard this I
used to be so triggered I was like what
i i t I've been but it's like if a girl
is a bum a man can love her right
because he he he loves like her more
than what she does but it's like if a
guy's a bum you know a girl can love him
but it's only for so long every YouTube
crush is or was someone named Wonder
hussy she does travel videos in remote
places in Nevada Arizona California Etc
I find your energy and Vibe really
appealing but after listening to her say
that she's originally from San Francisco
in a liberal Democrat I changed my mind
and interest I became indifferent and I
don't even care about politics mind you
I really haven't had anyone to crush on
for the last three or four years so I
fell for the whole female chameleon
thing plus she's a bit older in her
early 40s and I don't care about that
but I knew that once she started
speaking about the oppressed peoples
while she was driving around in a 4x4
paid by some ah I hate uh when women
talk about we're so oppressed just give
give me a break YouTube fan I just
couldn't listen to her anymore also now
when I see a woman that's overweight I
immediately think how much is she gonna
cost me in health care costs if I get
together with her in five to ten years
when I meet a woman that's a liberal or
a Marxist I think to myself how much is
she going to give me for working hard
and oppressing people with my effort
when I hear a woman that's a loud mouth
I wonder how long I could actually date
her without going crazy I've tried to be
with such women before and usually it's
only three to five weeks depending on
how much of an irritatrix she is when a
woman has a sister or sisters I think to
myself that her sister is the one that's
going to be butting her nose and
everything and if her sister doesn't
like me then neither will she damn I got
three assists outfit I got four sisters
I got five brothers too does it does it
even out if she likes to drink or smoke
I think to myself how long before she
gets drunk or high one night and cheats
on me if she likes taking pictures of
expensive food and exotic destinations
how long before I have to spend
thousands of dollars so she can take a
selfie of a taco in Morocco if I don't
take her on that trip that I won't get
access to her Taco in Morocco either
once you know about female nature and
behavior you can start to see patterns
in previous women's behavior when you
dated them all of a sudden it not only
gets tired and boring but you'd rather
be going to sleep alone instead of
dealing with the ladies on the rare
occasion you do find a woman that is
mostly great she's like a roller coaster
the line is long the ride is short and
there's a mile of guys behind you and a
mile of guys in front of you waiting to
get on occasionally with Wonder hussy
you'd actually see guys camping out with
her I don't really have to explain what
that's all about the reason we have
memories in life is not so we can
actually sit on a porch as old men one
day and reminisce about the good old
days when you and Beau drive around in
the General Lee through the swamps
chased by Roscoe Pico train but instead
it's about making sure you remember all
the times you got burned touching a hot
chick the reason all those women you
once found attractive are no longer
attractive to you is because you now
have experience or more importantly
you've connected red pill knowledge to
your real life experiences I get about
half a dozen guys a week commenting
about how my experiences in life were
late to there so well how when I
identify certain types of female
behaviors and motivations they can see
those reflected in their own experience
suddenly they have an aha moment while
listening to me and all begins to make
sense as men when we have our aha
moments we start to see female Behavior
differently if a woman we know nags at
us and we pretty much put her in her
place you may notice that quite often
this makes her happy immediately after
you do so you're standing up to her
testing and winning but it's taking its
toll on your psychological well-being
while the drama does nothing more than
Entertainer so if you get involved with
the woman and she immediately starts
testing you then you'll actually find
her unattractive because you know that
you'll have to keep winning one test
after another for the rest of the time
you talk to her it's a complete waste of
energy effort it will make you unhappy
because you know what it's all about so
you'll immediately find her unattractive
as a result you'll lose interest if the
woman is quiet and keeping her emotions
bottled up then you know that she's most
likely the quiet type and will use her
passive aggressive techniques like
gaslighting to manipulate you women are
different in the ways that they use
different techniques to manipulate late
man once you see this it's hard to be
attracted to women in general it doesn't
mean that you would be rather fudge
packing no matter how much women out
there try to shame you with that
suggestion it just means that you're
maturing and you don't want to deal with
childish games anymore that's why guys
find women less appealing after taking
the red pill because it has to do with
maturity in the past when life was
tougher short and brutal men grew up a
lot faster than they do today sure women
were still attractive but survival was
more important so men focused on one
over the other as life got physically
easier and women got physically Harder
They probably saw subconsciously that
some of that male effort that was
required before for mere survival could
be confiscated for their own personal
Amusement what many of them don't
realize is that male maturity means that
male effort doesn't get doled up like
Pez candies to a 200 pound kid maybe
that's why the media quite often
portrays men as childish buffoons
because if a man is a [__] he's likely
not to think about where his effort goes
and most of it might just go to a woman
it's like that line I throw around from
time to time women want an independent
man but they don't want him to think
independently would I make that's true
that's what a lot of the guys have been
interviewing for the documentary said
that the girl was perfectly fine until
he basically disobeyed her like she'd
been sort of running the relationship
he'd just been going along to get along
and then the second that he said no and
put his foot down on something that's
when like all hell froze over things
independently it's less likely that he's
gonna find women attractive for the way
that they look and nothing else instead
he'll probably carefully weigh the pros
and cons as the quality of women have
been degraded over the last 30 to 40
years men have been turned into zombies
with professional sports and bro culture
the media promotes mindless male
Behavior the only way that a typical man
finds the typical woman attractive is if
he's kept in the dark about female
nature suddenly when he sees the game
for what it really is he no longer finds
him as attractive they have to be that
one percent of women that do something
above and beyond the call of Kegel Duty
maybe they run a travel Adventure
YouTube channel or they're a hilarious
comedian or perhaps they have an amazing
personality that lights up a room
whenever they walk into it three he's in
red pill men find most women
unattractive is because it takes more
than a pretty smile and [__] Behavior
to Peak or curious
okay why do you think that women have
been using cooking as a way to attract
and keep men for most of History it's
the food stupid she's just hoping that
it's the Happy Happy Joy Joy feelings of
eating they keep you coming back for
more why do you think that so many women
in the red pill Community are going back
to faux traditionalism baking pies
Barefoot while wearing open back aprons
with their bottoms hanging out you know
why for easy access they're trying to
cover their modern bad attitudes with
the old southern hospitality they're
going back to the good old days of
beautifying their appearance instead of
putting on Daisy Dukes they're making
the food taste good and most importantly
acting Pleasant to be around they want
to look act and through their cooking
taste good too it's only been in the
last few Generations that women have
revealed their true nature to us is it
any Wonder than most of us red pilled
men can no longer find the majority of
them attractive we aren't looking at and
judging their physical Beauty and baked
goods which amounts to nothing more than
dog treats for men instead we're simply
looking at a female magician in her
misdirection she's covering her flaws
with virtues on the outside to reflect
the virtues that a man has on the inside
I ironically men are generally less
attractive on the outside than women and
we usually smell and look bad it's like
our outside body reflects their inside
mind and it's almost as if their outside
is supposed to reflect our inside it's
all about yeah and so I think his point
is that like a lot of times women don't
really do the inner work where it's like
they're trying to pretend to be
something that they're not
um and it's like
like if you've made certain decisions
with like sleeping around and that sort
of thing guys can just smell it on you
they can tell there ain't [__] you can
really do mirroring one another as a man
once you learn that a woman's
subconscious and conscious mind don't
mirror yours you don't actually find
you're all that attractive anymore you
find her to be compared to your own
personal value system and behavior so is
it any wonder that men going their own
way find most women unattractive and a
small percentage kind of iffy I don't
think it's a coincidence at all anyways
that's all I've got to say for today
thanks again miss fat cat and when you
actually have your son please don't call
him Mr Bigglesworth don't forget to
smash the like button the way that women
aren't getting smashed by red pill men
he's kind of funny
um okay
the MGT guys they're really just a
response to what women now we can
complain all we want and say they're
just focusing on the bad but I mean I
think when you compare like what women
were 100 years ago you understand where
they're coming from like I saw a picture
from England 100 years ago most of the
women had their hair covered they were
in like shawls and it's like do we have
that quality of women available today
not really and that's just being honest
right so um let me know what you guys
think in the comments um I'm a really
big fan of this channel so make sure you
go subscribe to it like the video on
your way out subscribe and I will talk
to you next time